très précis le 4 novembre prochain il ne
sera plus premier ministre désigné mais
bien premier ministre en exercice
passation des pouvoirs formation d'un
premier conseil des ministres conseil
des ministres paritaire hommes femmes il
l'a répété plus petit que les derniers
at il dit on verra le nombre précis avec
moi pour décortiquer parce qu'on en a eu
plein de sujets intéressants lors de
c'est de ce point de presse à la
question gay à montréal chantal hébert à
montréal emmanuelle latraverse de retour
à tahoua bonsoir messieurs dames
bonsoir bonsoir très intéressant
beaucoup de sujets premier tour de table
quand monsieur truc doit répéter et vers
la fin de la conférence de presse il a
dit une des choses qui me rend le plus
fier avec ces résultats c'est que on a
une présence maintenant partout au
canada évidemment au québec le québec
s'est réengagé dutil
c'est important et c'est un point de
départ pour lui qui lui donne qui lui
donne un bon et là en tout cas alec
chantal et emmanuel et laisse le seul
parti qui a une représentation dans
toutes les provinces actuellement donc
c'est clair qu'elle pour lui c'est un
avantage certain
il le fait un balayage complet en
atlantique a été chercher énormément de
sièges au québec qui n'avait pas été le
cas donc depuis 1988 aucun parti qui
était au gouvernement n'avait eu la
majorité des sièges au québec depuis
1988 avec brian mulroney donc c'est
quand même un changement qui est
important effectivement il fait des
percées pot énorme mais quand même en
alberta un siège toujours en
saskatchewan don qui est assez
représentatif
parce qu'il me re peut-être le plus le
plus étonné ou du moins le plus marqué
de cette conférence de presse la cpo
temps les contenus qui effectivement et
les choses intéressantes mais comme le
format de la conférence de presse
un premier ministre assise au théâtre
national de la presse qui reçoit plus
que quatre questions qui sont posées par
des journalistes qui peuvent imposer
plus qu'une ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu ça donc une vraie
conférence de presse à bonne et due
forme ce sa tranche aussi avec le style
de steve nash et d'ailleurs c'est la
première phrase qu'il a tenu à dire il à
dire la presse est important dans notre
démocratie
je vous salut bonjour messieurs dames
j'avais une longue campagne
chantal
intéressant ça m'a permis de constater
qui s'est fait pas mal de rénovation
d'ailleurs au théâtre de la presse un
endroit qu'on a si peu fréquentés au
cours des dernières années mais ça me
rappelait aussi parce que vous étiez là
quand stephen harper est arrivé la
tribune de la presse de façon générale
ça la dérange pas tellement la couleur
politique du gouvernement qui arrive un
nouveau gouvernement c'est toujours un
cadeau pour des tribunes de la presse
qu'une page blanche sur laquelle on va
pouvoir écrire à des nouveaux ministres
nouveau programme et je me suis adapté
le premier point de presse de stephen
harper après les sélections avait fait
ça dans l'anti chambre des communes
d'ailleurs ça avait franchement très
très bien été et en écoutant justin
trudeau je me suis dit ou est-ce que ça
à des tapis tout cela parce que monsieur
harper aurait pu lui aussi avoir une
relation constructive avec la tribune de
la presse c'est sûr que ce sera pas un
robin fallait jamais mais le contraste
était tellement frappante ça n'a pas
commencé comme ça pour ceux qui veulent
un peu non plus exactement et emmanuelle
seigner frappant aussi pu aussi beaucoup
de questions là dessus c'est qu'il ya
des rendez-vous des tests internationaux
importants qui arrivent pour monsieur
trudeau oui d'une certaine façon ces
tests internationaux brusque la donne et
les échéanciers également auxquels il
est confronté dans la formation de son
gouvernement dans les choix que lui
devra prendre pourquoi parceque bon mais
seront là beaucoup parlé de la
conférence de paris sur les changements
climatiques au mois de novembre que
plusieurs avaient oublié on en parlait
tard asseoir dans la nuit c'est ce
sommet du g20 également qui aura lieu en
turquie où on va parler
la question des réfugiés la guerre
contre le groupe armé islamique et
utérin qu'il suivit tout de suite après
quelques jours à peine d'une rencontre
des pays de l'asie pacifique ou bien sûr
commercy international partenariat
transpacifique seront à l'agenda
on a entendu monsieur trudeau d'écouté
c'est certain que je vais à paris
pour les autres on va voir on va essayer
d'y aller c'est une image in et comment
il raterait c'est important rendez vous
en tout début de mandat lui même
reconnaît qu'il ya un jeu d'équilibré
pour lui a trouvé là dedans
entre
s'attaquer rapidement à des dossiers
cruciaux pour la sécurité économique la
sécurité aussi nationale du canada et
mettre son gouvernement tout nouveau sur
les rails là ce qui est quand même pas
une mince affaire non plus et dans et il
a dit pour paris le dire et dont j'ai
parlé à plusieurs premiers ministres
provinciaux les relations
fédérales-provinciales chantal là on
vient de changer d'ère aussi ouais comme
à chaque changement de gouvernement
c'est bien accueilli parce que au fil du
temps les provinces ottawa ne s'entend
que jamais s'est jamais la parfaite
harmonie sexuelle des griefs qui
s'accumulent des rancunes il ya des
campagnes électorales on a vu les
conservateurs faire campagne contre
kathleen wynne de toutes sortes de
façons y compris en campagne fédérale
donc l'arrivée d'un nouveau premier
ministre
d'abord tout le monde se dit on passe un
autre équipier au début ils font écouter
toutes nos demandes parce qu'ils
viennent d'être élus vous le sentez dans
les grandes villes de toronto montréal
qui sait le gorille tient les cordons de
la bourse pour changer mais pour revenir
à ce que manuel disait sur le conseil
des ministres ça veut dire que monsieur
harper a besoin rapidement deux
ministres fonctionnel sur le front de
l'environnement
donc quelqu'un qui n'est pas un junior
et qui va être capable de se débrouiller
un ministre des affaires étrangères et
de la défense parce que les partenaires
du canada vont vouloir savoir demain
matin comment on voit ça la coalition
sur d'état islamique est évidemment lui
même va devoir payer de sa personne
une ministre des finances une évidence
or ce conseil des ministres en plus
détecteur il va falloir qu'il fasse une
certaine place à l'expérience parce que
c'est pas le genre de programme commun
d'ici noël qui permet d'aller faire ses
classes en maternelle mais c est parce
que ça prend de l'expérience par exemple
hier soir on s'amusait déjà un peu
asseyez de prédire ici ou là des non
monsieur dion par exemple comme ministre
de l'environnement ce serait logique
mais ça voudrait aussi que ils vont les
minus fort combien dans ses
portefeuilles là on va falloir vivre
avec moi ça m'a frappé dans le fameux
courriels de damian
l'ancien conseiller de campagne qui est
dit une compagnie pétrolière
vous devriez vous mettre bien avec le
ministre des finances ça m'avait frappé
que le coyote du depor est aussi avec
celui de l'environnement parce qu'il va
contribuer beaucoup dans notre
gouvernement
mais une fois qu'on aime un minus
l'environnement et stéphane guillon
il va falloir c'est comme d'antan onuci
mme fisher a été ministre fédéral de
l'environnement
c'était bien pour monsieur m'entraîner
mais fallait vivre avec au quotidien et
alec est ce que j'avais envie de plonger
quelques noms finance par exemple est
juste pour compléter sur chantal avant
et ce niveau de ce que tu m'en moquais
quand on est ministre l'environnement
10e stéphane dion quand lui et ottawa
que doute à être fort tu le sais c'est
pas nécessairement toujours fait pour
s'entendre mais effectivement stéphane
dion est probablement le plus près à
servait humour une conférence tout comme
celle de paris et non seulement préservé
pour la connaissance des dossiers mais
pour avoir les connexions aussi à
l'international que ça prend pour
naviguer dans une rencontre comme celle
là parce que au-delà du fait d'avoir
effectivement une politique si c'est
qu'il faut être capable de savoir
comment le canada va s'insérer dans ce
jeu là à lui tiré son épingle du jeu
puis stéphane dion est capable de faire
je pense qu'au final ce rendez-vous un
juste une petite aparté latu rappelez
vous il avait été applaudi dans cette
conférence internationale je pense est
le seul ministre qui comprenait de rased
tous les petits points ils avaient
vraiment il faut lui donner sauf facile
de voir mes demandé à ses collègues du
cabinet de l'époque comme un fait un
empêcheur de tourner en rond à cause de
ses connaissances
très bien ça c'est l'environnement
finances quand même deux trois ans alec
pour avec moi je pense que bill morneau
est presque une évidence la mois qu'on
se trompe mais disons que le président
fondateur de la grande firme de
consultants un morneau shepell à toronto
toronto qui tenait très connu à bay
street qui serait très rassurant qu'une
maîtrise la langue d'une secours avec un
amx pourrait très bien jouer ce rôle là
je pense que c'est une évidence ce qu
andrew leslie lancé chef d'état major
des forces canadiennes de l'armée de
terre peut aller mettre en place la
fameuse réforme qui prônait à l'époque
parce qu'il fait un rapport au
gouvernement harper sur la manière de
réformer les forces canadiennes
est-ce qui trop associée à ce rapport là
où est-ce qu'on contraire on veut mettre
en place ce qui lui prenait à l'époque
ça ça pourrait être intéressant
je pense que bill blair à la sécurité
publique l'ancien chef de police de
toronto qui est maintenant connu à
travers
pays pour s'opposer à rob ford va
certainement tirer au cabinet aussi mais
il ya une belle brochette quand même
justin trudeau le potentiel ministre et
plusieurs toiles et plus de choix au
québec qui ne pensait avec 40 on ait
manuel hier on parlait de ces jeunes
vedettes que le grand public connaît -
peut-être comme françois philippe
champagne dans saint maurice champlain
pourrait faire son entrée au cabinet de
jean chrétien moindre but il déjà 28
exactement où il a beaucoup aidé oui
parce qu'avec les députés qui ont été
lus à l'extérieur de montréal c'est soit
que sûrement sur l'île de montréal il
faut aussi mentionner quelqu'un comme
mélanie joly du cil d'imaginer qu'elle
ne serait pas nommé au conseil des
ministres mais en effet françois
philippe champagne qui lui est avocat
une vaste expérience à l'international
c'est quelqu'un qui est pressenti
également pour le conseil du ministre et
il ya une vedette peu connu du public
mais très apprécié de monsieur trudeau
qui avait tellement peu de chances de se
faire élire qu'on ne mettait pas sûr
nouveau liste des ministrables mais qui
a réussi hier à passer c'est monsieur
duclos à québec
économiste de l'université laval jean
claude jean yves duclos donc lui aussi
c'est sur la liste des personnes et de
faire leur entrée au congé chanter
d'ailleurs la bombe a fait le ménage
dans son sang kardex ma famille a mis en
lui sans du cloud à haut de la liste
descendu un peu bleynie mais les
connaissances en envoyant we let express
à monsieur trudeau je veux mon binôme à
québec d'ailleurs le maire de montréal
aussi était radieux je peux vous avez vu
son point de presse aujourd'hui était
content est bon mais ça y est on a plus
de péage sur le pont champlain en valeur
c'est le retour du courrier à domicile
entre qu'on veut on voit on est bon on
ouvre quelques portes
montréal qui est le maire de montréal
qui est très très heureux je veux qu'on
parle avant qu'on se quitte des autres
chefs
monsieur monsieur un peu hier qui a
démissionné de son poste de chef d'une
drôle de façon
comment vous voyez cette course et
comment vous voyez l'introspection au
parti conservateur déjà jason kenney
nous à notre émission hier soir
ouvert la machine déjà on était un peu
obsédé on était toujours en colère faut
changer d'attitude
je vous entends de là dessus avec ce qui
va être intéressant c'est que stephen
harper laisse son parti en relativement
bonne santé autant sur le plan financier
où la machine à ramasser de l'argent du
parti conservateur est toujours aussi
efficace
également en nombre de sièges près d'une
centaine de sièges se ressemble beaucoup
plus à une défaite à la halle à jean
charest au québec laquelle et si le
parti libéral du québec en bonne santé
malgré la déroute après andy que une kim
kembo par exemple qui laisse le parti
conservateur complètement désorganisée
donc son successeur de quoi bâtir une
fondation assez fort par contre il n'y a
jamais eu de chef de ce type de parti
lost a dit que c'est stephen harper qui
réunit la droite qui a mené le mouvement
conservateur lowy lit et qui ont imprimé
donc la direction au parti il n'est
jamais eu donc de chef depuis ce temps
le comment on peut se positionner par
exemple un chef un peu plus
progressistes sur l' axe est ce qu ils
capables de récupérer le produit de la
manière dont il est actuellement et d'en
faire son parti le lait des questions
qui se posent et qui vont être
intéressantes à regarder amir méchant
terre une course au leadership c'est
précisément ça ça va oui et là on va se
battre
certains disent ils sont méchants quel
parti conservateur a perdu son âme
parce que monsieur harper de trop habité
mais dans l'avion ce matin y avait
quelqu'un qui a été qu un conseiller
très très proche de jim flaherty qui
connaît bien ces parties là c'est pas
mener de la campagne qu'ils disent est
ce que les gens se rendent pas compte
c'est comment ce parti là est difficile
à diriger si tu veux n'a plus réussi à
faire ça mais une figure comme ceux qui
va réussir à unir le parti et à le
garder à l'empêcher d'éclater regardez
ce qui se passe en alberta avec les
conservateurs
ça vous donne une idée cette personne là
on peut voir john kani comme favori par
ce qui est mieux placé pour gagner s'il
veut le poste mais on peut pas le voir
nécessairement comme bien placé pour
unir ces factions et ouvert la machine
new year et emmanuel comme envoyer cette
course qui commence c'est une course
délicate pour l'avenir du parti comme le
dit chantal parce que
l'unité de ce parti il a relevé aussi de
la discipline de fer qui a imposé
monsieur à peu c'était un peu la
fragilité de ces mariages de convenance
rappelez-vous qui explique en partie
cette façon très autoritaire de diriger
son propre pays qui avait son propre
parti pardon qui avait monsieur harper
est-ce que jason kenny lui peut
convaincre lait le plus progressiste du
parti sont aussi s'est pas fait non plus
qui est intéressant c'est que dans les
cercles ici à travailler déjà un autre
nom qui circule beaucoup c'est celui du
premier ministre de la saskatchewan brad
wall quand faudra-t-il s'il veut devenir
l'opposition officielle il apprend la
logistique français là dessus c'est bon
les césar c'est l'indicateur un premier
bien sûr la conférence de presse vous en
mangez un peu de temps c'est tout pour
ce soir on va parler au cours des
prochains jours bien sûr de l'avenir de
gilles duceppe il doit de prendre une
décision et l'annoncé surtout peut-être
qu'elle est déjà prise jeudi et monsieur
mulcair
il leur a peut-être aussi à réfléchir à
peut-être des couteaux qui vont se
lancer en verre en reparler merci
infiniment pour votre collaboration
encore une fois en avant
à voir